dolor e incertidumbre fuera de este
penal de guayaquil los familiares
esperan a las puertas del centro
penitenciario respuestas sobre la
situación de los internos después de una
violenta jornada de disturbios dentro de
tres carteles del ecuador
que deja más de 70 muertos
nada no nos dicen nada solo dice que ya
está tranquilo está tranquilo pero
adentro dicen que nuevo está el problema
y no nos dan ninguna respuesta no nos
dan ninguna respuesta para nosotros
estar un poco más tranquilo me entiende
ellos tienen vídeos no sé cómo le han
llegado vídeos de personas en el piso
muertas tantas cosas que se ven y
créanme lo que estaban en los cárceles
de cuadros se encontraban en una
situación crítica pero en los últimos
años la violencia interna se ha
convertido en una constante hasta que el
martes la lucha entre dos bandas
criminales por mantener el liderazgo se
salió de control
desatando motines simultáneos en tres
penales del país que aglutina la 70% de
la población carcelaria de ecuador según
las autoridades la situación está ahora
bajo control o de que el ejército fuera
desplegado para sofocar la revuelta
hemos tenido hoy el apoyo frontal de
policía nacional alrededor de 800
servidores policiales entre oficiales
clases y policías han apoyado para
y poder controlar
y poner nuevamente
el orden dentro de los centros de
privación de la libertad los grupos de
derechos humanos atacan la escalada de
violencia a las deficiencias en el
sistema penitenciario ecuatoriano con
capacidad para albergar a 29 mil
reclusos el panorama real es una
población interna de 38 mil personas y
1.500 guardias para supervisarlos